when I used to pick my daughter from
school when she was little from
elementary school I'd be in the middle
of the schoolyard and kids would run up
to me and say you could train and solo
and I found myself having to justify
this character's behavior and his his
actions
I mean I'd go on an airplane and I've
had the stewardess saying you betrayed
head solo he didn't really betray Han
Solo what he did he was trying to to
prevent the complete demise of Han Solo
and his friends because he had no choice
when you're dealing with Darth Vader and
you know Lando did stand up to Darth
Vader for about two seconds and realized
that it could be a huge mistake but he
had to do he had to come up with a
devised something so he had to come up
with something in order to try to keep
his situation going which he finally
ended up losing and as a result anyway